Do you love Harry Potter? Would you like to be able to
understand these movies even without the subtitles?
Well today let’s train your ears to understand the
native speech in Harry Potter just like magic.
Our community member Diana said that thanks to our lessons
she is getting confident listening and even speaking skills!
You will, too because every week we make lesson
to help you understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost, without
missing the jokes, and without subtitles.
So join over 4.5 million learners from around
the world who are making learning English fun,
just like Diana did. Hit the subscribe button and the
bell down below and you won’t miss a single new lesson!
By the way, do you ever feel lost when we
natives speak fast? It’s frustrating, isn’t it?
We cut some words. We connect others.  It does not
sound anything like what you learned in school.
That’s why in our Fluent with Friends course
we take you outside of the classroom
and help you learn English as it is really spoken,
and have a ton of fun doing it with Friends,
which various academic studies show is the best
TV series out there for learning English.
Can you imagine being able to understand English
as effortlessly as you understand your native language?
Well you CAN, just like our
student, Jonas! And guess what?
You can try it absolutely
free with our 3-part masterclass!
So learn more and sign up by clicking up
here or down in the description below now.
I hope you enjoyed learning
with Harry Potter today.
If you can’t get enough of our lessons with
your favorite TV series, movies, and songs,
then make sure that you follow us over on our Instagram
because we make new lessons there every single day.
By the way, do you remember the epic
part of Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azakaban
where Hermione punches Draco? I remember
when I saw this movie for the first time at the cinema
and everyone clapped their hands
in that moment. Let’s take a look!